the White House is undergoing a 3.4
million dollar renovation renovating the
White House yeah yeah Trump said he's
hoping to replace the kitchen the
carpeting and the Attorney General they
have those at Bed Bath & Beyond yeah
there's a contractor with the tape
measure measuring jeff says yeah yeah
yeah those are big ears we can take
those off oh come on this guy was like
hey you shouldn't sawed off his ears
yeah that was cheering me a minute ago
now he's upset a lot of speculation
about Vice President Mike Pence yeah
vice president Mike Pence denies he says
he denies he's planning to run for
president in 2020 yeah he said I'm
pretty sure I'll be president way before
them
wait I have a little hoedown for myself
when I really like a job you heard about
what's going on at Fox News right Fox
News has suspended a host after he
admitted to sending unsolicited dick
pics yeah now of course at Fox News
sending unsolicited dick pics is usually
how you get the job that's the problem
that's what was that there was no laughs
which is fine you exercised your
privilege not to laugh then there was an
eerie pause and then everyone clap
I don't know what to do with that
President Trump has been complaining on
Twitter that the press is not reporting
his accomplishments yeah
that's what he say he's saying they're
not out there he's mad they're not
reporting his accomplishments yeah the
press respond to be would but we're not
allowed to print the word cluster
they were so thrilled I was leaving that
hurt my job here's something if for you
science people out there I love stories
about space and exploration that's me
half nerd I got one guy to go with me
and I I turned on him I apologize I say
no the Mars Curiosity rover celebrated
its fifth year in space by humming happy
birthday to itself
yeah the rover then drank a bottle of
white wine and cried itself to sleep and
then in the morning it shot itself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I just picture waking up with a hangover
happy birthday to me you try being a
rover out there it's not easy
towing oh sure oh sure that's right I'm
gonna say uh sure uh sure is being sued
for millions because he failed to
disclose to a sexual partner that he has
herpes
yeah in a related story Steven Tyler has
fled the country he was last seen on
Mars tower should flee the planet yeah
exactly
the Mars is like now thank you I've
heard where you've been folks these are
really good you're gonna love them later
police in Pennsylvania are looking for a
woman who performed oral sex on a man at
a McDonald's yeah police police looking
for yeah in fact every man in
Pennsylvania
you
you